well we all know if we watch the movie
wolf of wallstreet the story of Jordan
Belfort and the fortune he made in penny
stock well turns out there's a new wolf
of Wall Street in town though he's never
worked on Wall Street Josh sazon is 27
years old
invested 200 million dollars in penny
stocks himself and penny bets
Bloomberg's Zeke Fox and joins me now a
great article Zeke in Bloomberg
Businessweek on this so what do we know
about this 27 year old millionaire who
was what six years ago living with his
parents in Long Island yes he was in a
band hoping to be a rock star when he
learned this one weird legal trick that
lets you make huge returns on penny
stocks which are usually a horrible
investment right and the way that it
works is he instead of just buying the
stock loans companies money and then
gets in return millions or even billions
of shares at a big discount to the
market price even so the loans convert
into stock then yes at a huge discounted
price so what happens if those companies
go bankrupt or they go to zero what
happens then it doesn't matter how low
the companies go as long as there's a
market for the shares if the stock goes
to a penny he gets it for say half a
penny if it goes to a thousandth of a
penny he gets it for half a thousandth
of a penny so he can always make money
unless the market totally dries up right
right exactly then he then he's out of
luck so tell me a little bit about this
guy I mean as I mentioned so six years
ago he was living with his parents on
the island what is he like now I mean
you know just how does he spend his
money where is he investing he's sort of
like a mini Richard Branson he's
producing a movie with Martin Scorsese
called bleed for this starring miles
teller it's a boxing biopic okay
then he's in London he's mixing an album
by this Israeli model he's signed to his
record label he's got a sort of
Kickstarter that helps bands sell albums
ahead of time he's got a receptionist
company he's doing all sorts of
different things he's really diversified
away from this penny stock thing which
is where he made his fortune so he
doesn't does he like those comparisons
to Jordan Belfort he actually doesn't
that no and I think that's a little mean
Belfort would actually you know the
basis for the wolf of wallstreet he's
calling old people and tricking them
into buying worthless stocks and
basically stealing their money so stone
has come up with this legal trick to
finance desperate penny stock companies
that enables him to make big profits
doesn't actually involve going out and
tricking retirees Hobbs right exactly
and and and and manipulating them okay
so if this is something that is very
lucrative and it's legal so why doesn't
every hedge fund do this then well
there's a limit to how much you can
scale it up because these are tiny
companies so he's doing these
investments uh generally a hundred
thousand or a million at a time the
other thing is that it is pretty sketchy
a lot of the companies that do what
someone has done have gotten sued by the
SEC one guy who did it actually got
arrested by the FBI because they took
shortcuts there's a way to do it legally
but there's easy to maybe get into
getting some legal trouble yeah the law
it's a pretty gray area and it's hard to
know exactly what's right and what's
wrong so most people don't want to go
there and also maybe they never knew
that there were such big money to be
made all right exactly all right Zee
thank you so much on that on Josh sazon
Bloomberg's
Zeke [ __ ]